-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
We're about to play a new game
called "Cold as Ice."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Cold as Ice ♪
-♪ Cold as ice ♪
-♪ Ice ♪
-To play, I'll be...
[ Laughter ]
...facing off against
an amazing actor
who stars in the movie
"The Lost City."
Give it up for Daniel Radcliffe,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello!
-♪ Ice ♪
-Now, Tariq --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks.
-Tariq, tell them how it works.
♪♪
-[Laughing] Well!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I'll alternate asking each
of you the trivia questions.
-Uh-huh.
-If you answer wrong,
I'll pour a pitcher of ice water
down the tube of death,
delivering it directly
to your crotch.
-Oh, well. Okay.
-However,
if you answer correctly,
your opponent gets iced instead.
Are you ready?
-Yes!
-Let's do this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Daniel, the first question
is for you.
Your new movie, "The Lost City,"
is about a romance novelist --
-You can't ask him
about his own movie!
-Which of the following
is not the name
of a real romance novel
that you can buy right now
if you were to go book shopping
for a romance novel
at the romance novel shop?
[ Laughter ]
Is it "A," "The Bull Rider's
Christmas Baby?"
[ Light laughter ]
"B," "My Zombie Werewolf
Mistress?"
-Oh...
Or "C,"
"But...You're a Horse"?
[ Laughter ]
-Aw, I really thought
these would be gettable.
-Yes.
-Um -- okay, I mean,
I'm gonna go "C,"
"But...You're a Horse."
-The correct answer was...
[ Buzzer ]
"My Zombie Werewolf Mistress."
[ Audience ohs ]
-Give it to me!
-[ Laughs ]
-Daniel, that is incorrect.
It's time for you to get iced.
-Do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Okay. Okay.
This is -- yeah.
Yeah.
-It's real?
-Oh, it's okay. It keeps going.
There's a lot.
It's still coming.
-Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Good. Good.
-Wow.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
-Yeah! That's right!
-Great.
-We're out of time.
We'll be right back.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, time for
the next question.
Jimmy, this one is for you.
-Yeah.
"The Lost City" also stars
the always-effervescent
Sandra Bullock.
-Mm.
In Sandra's classic movie
"Speed," the bus will explode
if it falls below what speed?
-I know this.
-Now, I think the speed limit,
I would say is probably --
50 would be normal.
55, Sammy Hagar.
60 is too fast.
But 60 is --
is actually speeding.
♪♪
-Jimmy, what is your answer?!
-Wait --
If 50 is going normal,
55 is normal maybe.
60 is speeding.
My answer is 60.
'Cause it's called "Speed."
[ Buzzer ]
-The correct answer
was 50 miles per hour.
-Oh, God!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy, you get the ice.
-Okay, thank you.
["Ice, Ice Baby" plays ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
-♪ Ice ♪
-Daniel, back to you.
The story
of the lost city of Atlantis
originally comes from
the ancient Greeks.
Atlantis is, of course, a
fictional island mentioned in --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah!
What's the question?!
-An allegory on the hubris of
nations in the work of Plato.
Which of these things finds --
-Ask the question, please!
-Which of these things you'd --
-Ask the question!
-Which of these things you'd
find in your kitchen is --
gets its name
from an ancient Roman God?
-Okay.
-Is it "A," refrigerator...
-"B," faucet, or "C," cereal.
-"B", a faucet...
or "C," cereal.
-Um -- [ Stammers ]
Refrigerator!
[ Buzzer ]
-The correct answer was cereal.
♪♪
-Okay.
-Named after Ceres,
the Goddess of grain.
Daniel, you got it wrong
yet again.
Time for you to get iced!
♪♪
-Come on, spread it 'round.
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
-The second one --
-Yeah.
-The second one is harder
than the first one, right?
-It really is -- it really is --
it's very right leg heavy,
but it's an incredibly cold
right leg.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Ice ♪
-Way back in 1997 --
-Oh, my heavens.
-[ Laughs ]
-The world was first introduced
to a young wizard
with a heart of gold.
His name, Harry Potter.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-In "Harry Potter
and the Prisoner of Azkaban" --
-Yes, of course.
-What spell do you cast
to turn someone
into something funny?
[ Laughter ]
Is it "A," Guffawedify?
"B," Riddikulus?
Or "C," "Prepostumsempra"?
-Guffawedify.
I'm going to say it's "A,"
Guffawedify.
[ Buzzer ]
-Incorrect!
-Darn it!
The correct answer --
-Riddikulus?
-The correct was "Riddikulus."
-All right, here we go.
-Ice time!
[ Laughs evilly ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's kick some ice.
-Uh-oh.
When we hear the voice of
Mr. Freeze...
-Yeah?
-As everyone knows, that means
it's time for the final round.
-Yes.
-The loser gets the ice hose.
[ Cheers ]
The ice cold hose water will --
will go down your funnel and --
and keep on flowing
until we go to commercial.
[ Laughter ]
Okay!
-Yeah.
-Have your dry erase boards
and markers ready.
-You -- put an extra couple
cubes in that --
-Here's your question!
How many calories are
in one little carton
of "The Tonight Dough" flavor
of Ben & Jerry's ice cream?
-Oh, this is guessing.
-You have 10 seconds,
starting now!
♪♪
-I -- I --
-No, yeah -- okay, yeah.
-There's -- there's chocolate
in there.
-In the whole --
♪♪
-Time's up!
[ Buzzer ]
Jimmy, what did you write down?
-I have no clue.
980 calories?
-I think that's --
-Daniel, what is your answer?
-1,300.
-The correct answer was 1,210
calories!
Daniel, you are the winner!
[Bell dinging]
-He overbid!
You overbid!
-No!
-I'm sorry, Jimmy.
Time for the ice hose!
[ Laughs evilly ]
♪♪
-That is -- that is carrying its
own velocity.
That's a different thing.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause,
laughter ]
♪♪
-All right, we'll be right back,
after the break.
We'll be right back with
Daniel Radcliffe, everybody.
Come on back.